[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show what so far hundreds and
hundreds of challengers no winners
nobody has caught us making a mistake ah
was a little much yeah that was kind of
gloaty
yeah well tonight a fan named Corinne
Sam Morrison says she thinks she caught
a mistake she says it happened during a
comedy sketch when Andy said a word in
Japanese what hi Colin I was watching
your show the other night and you were
doing an international news edition and
I couldn't help but notice that your pal
Andy mispronounced the word oh yes I
mean outside the goodnight in Japanese
and because I figured that you might
want to show me up I decided to ask some
of my Japanese friends how to say it has
proof so without further ado hey how do
you say good night in Japanese like how
do you say good night in Japanese yes
how do you say good night in Japanese oh
yes hi how do you say good night in
Japanese how's that
yeah well sorry carrenza but you are
dead wrong and ii did in fact pronounce
that word correctly and guess what
i also have four japanese friends ready
to back me up check it out hey George
Takei say how do you say good night in
Japanese how do you say good night in
Japanese or assuming this side
[Applause]
[Music]
our thanks to George Takei and to his
sister Georgina for helping us out yeah
so the challenge still stands still
stands if you think you've spotted an
error on our show reported at team
koco.com slash haha I found an error we
will sort it out fairly and impartially
here on the air as we always do
[Applause]